I'm shocked when I watch those videos
online of you and Axel Rose I can't
think of like something that I would
think would never happen Carrie
Underwood and Axel Rose like being pals
like you've performed with guns and
roses and he's come and performed with
your band yeah and I see him up there
and I go this is crazy that YouTube like
like how does that all come about
um I mean I've I've been a fan since
almost birth
um you know as a very small child I felt
like his voice is something that just
cut through the air to me amazing voice
right yes and just doing things that
were different he didn't sound like
everybody else and you know sometimes it
wasn't it wasn't pretty it was it was
like that's not what the song was meant
for he was willing to you know get into
the song and do what the song needed and
his voice just did different things so
as a kid you were probably like wow Guns
and Roses really cool I love his voice
you know what they we didn't have MTV we
didn't have like we we had five five
stations on the on the television right
all we had was the radio and the things
that my sisters would listen to so it's
like I just knew his voice I didn't know
anything about the man I mean as a
five-year-old seven-year-old whatever
you don't know who's singing it you just
know you like that right how does this
come about that like you're hanging with
Axel Rose and then doing a Guns and
Roses thing we've covered DNR for I mean
since the beginning what did you cover
Paradise City patients wow
um I think we've done we've done
November Rain November rail you must do
a great rendition of that what a song
After the cry pretty tour wrapped
um I was like hey everybody banned let's
we're into Detroit I think right and I
was like Hey like let's go to Vegas and
see Guns and Roses because they were
playing a couple shows there so we went
and I never anytime I go to a concert
like I I kind of don't I don't want to
be in the way right I just want to go
and enjoy myself but they were like oh
you know you want to say hi afterwards
and I was like you know nervous right
yes even though you're famous even
though you've had tremendous success
it's like those guys are like a little
intimidating not a little a lot
intimidating and cool right I just I am
not worthy I'm not worthy to breathe to
breathe the oxygen then what do they do
they March you backstage and you're what
suddenly talking to Axel and slam yeah
and he took me back to his dressing room
and I just got to chat with him for a
few minutes I don't even know it was a
blow what do you even say I don't know
we talked for a minute about the show
and about touring and stuff like that
and right but I I've been trying to sing
with him for many years and we had asked
for Stagecoach last year and because
they were like we're in your neck of the
woods you know we know you're you're
kind of gearing up for tour so maybe
you're in that mode and I wrote an email
and sent it and was just explained why
because it does sound unexpected yeah
it's great but I think just knowing you
know what an influence he was and is to
me I also think like it's wild when
you're performing with him you start to
dance like him you do the whole we we
have fun I think and that's the thing
about like when I'm on stage by myself
that's one thing but then when there's
like somebody else you get to play off
of
um you know it's it's just a different
energy it's a different vibe
foreign